staffing issues have been an ongoing
problem for businesses for months and
staff getting sick from kova due to the
new strain really taking a toll eight
news now reporter sally jaramillo is
live with one grocery store and how
they're coping with those shortages
sally here at market 10 supermarket
they're dealing with the many stresses
many businesses are dealing with right
now but the shelves remain stuck i
contacted several other grocery
operators today and i'm told despite
staffing shortages they will do
everything they can to continue serving
our community
we've been
doing
a business during the pandemic for the
last 20 months now and so we have
learned a lot
we're following the science brian
wachter at the retail association of
nevada says grocers have been working
very diligently despite kovac cases
rising he reminds customers there's no
reason to change your shopping habits
just be prepared to find alternate
brands i will say that you might find a
product that's out
your special product or your favorite
brand might be out
and we ask folks to be a little flexible
like that or check another store
according to wachter retail employment
has increased almost all retailers are
looking at how they're providing
compensation
they've been providing bonuses since the
beginning of the pandemic base pay has
increased albertson's providing bonuses
and marketing supermarket district
manager joel estrada saying they bumped
up pay we give
raises to all the employees just to keep
the ones we have
because everybody is fighting for
help estrada says with the holidays he
did see a spike in employees getting
sick in some of the areas we have to
close early or we have big lines
sometimes we are doing our best to serve
the community
back out live grocers remind you to be
patient with them as many employees are
working extra hours now here at mark
attended the number of staff continues
to rise they will definitely consider
also reducing and limiting their hours
for now reporting live sally caramillo
live local now